so you're one of the
prominent i would say even the faces of
the
the world of cryptocurrency bitcoin
that whole entire world let's dive
straight in and ask uh
do you think do you consider yourself a
bitcoin
maximalist i think that the way i really
look at it is
uh i work backwards off of what is the
maximalism that i believe in and the
world that i believe in
is kind of an automated world that is
run on these open decentralized
protocols
uh and what we ultimately do is we
return
sovereignty and individualism and kind
of
personal responsibility and liberty uh
to people over institutions
and what we end up doing is we end up uh
kind of taking
what has historically been a very analog
or physical world economy
and geographic rule and we then
kind of put it in the cloud and this
digital economy becomes the prevalent
way that we all
uh conduct commerce communicate etc and
so
it's less about any one single
technology to me right i think that it's
pretty stupid for people to
um almost in a way uh put an inanimate
object
up for uh you know some sort of
obsession
uh to me it's much more about the ideals
the ethos
uh and the most rational uh and likely
path
to that kind of end result or that world
that i think you know is at this point
just a foregone conclusion so the
distinction there
and maybe people don't know the
terminology maximalism is basically
saying i really think this is a good
idea
like uh you know if you prefer a certain
kind of diet
you could be a keto maximalist saying
like this is probably
maybe it's not 100 but probably the diet
that's healthiest for humans kind of
thing
in the same sense bitcoin maximalism is
saying
you know of course we don't know there's
a lot of uncertainty but this particular
technology
seems to be the best representations of
some set of ideals
that defines progress in in the future
but you're drawing a distinction between
sort of uh
cult-like obsession about an object of
any
kind whether it's keto uh or uh
bitcoin and just sort of believing
that a technology is the best
representation of a particular set of
ideals
and you believe that sort of uh
this moving into the cloud uh
both the distributed nature of it but
also just the digital nature of it
is something that's going to uh be a
positive step for humanity
yeah i would even take maximosm a step
further and it's not just the
kind of singular viewpoint of this is
the best
it's also uh an element of it's
anti-everything else
right so you know take keto for example
the keto diet is not only the best diet
all the other diets are bad yeah right
and so it's it's a very binary view of
the world
um i think that what's probably most
misunderstood about uh
let's take bitcoin as a specific example
is that
most of the people who are labeled
bitcoin maximalist
they would be open-minded if they
believed that something else came along
that was a superior
technology or had a better kind of
probability of achieving
again that ultimate vision i think where
uh
there's this controversy and kind of
clashing of uh
ideas is that the bitcoin community
believes bitcoin is the best way to do
that
and has very specific arguments as to
why the other things are not
right and so what ultimately ends up
happening which is very weird
in uh the investing world right it's
unlikely that you and i are going to sit
down you're like apple stock is the best
stock and there's no other stock that's
worth anything
yeah right and uh and then also it's
very weird if you said to me
um you know this stock is worth zero and
that's where
everything that i own i've put on a
short on one single company
right there's diversification there's
much more kind of probabilistic thinking
in finance in general
uh when it comes to this specific world
of cryptocurrency and kind of digital
assets if you will
uh is there's two main groups of people
who are trying to build two
very very different things at the onset
but when you unpack it and you start to
spend more time on it you realize
they're actually trying to accomplish
the same thing in two different ways
so bitcoin is seen i think as a digital
currency right kind of the idea that
this is going to ascend to become the
next global reserve currency
it's a programmatic kind of transparent
um money
and uh it's essentially just 180 degrees
difference than the inflationary
you know non-transparent uh fiat
currencies that exist in the world
you then look at kind of everything else
right and you have a lot of smart
contract platforms and
various things that they're all going
after right ethereum with kind of the
world computer
approach and you can kind of go down the
line with all their other arguments so
what they're trying to build
i think the big difference just comes
down to uh
innovation for security and when you
simplistically look at it via that lens
you
actually understand where both people
are coming from when you say security
start to interrupt
do you mean financial security or do you
mean like literally the the the security
of the
of the particular cryptocurrency the the
technical security of a blockchain so
when you look at let's say
um bitcoin versus ethereum right bitcoin
has decided and that community has
decided
security is the number one thing that
you have to optimize for so
decentralization
um over everything else in terms of
transaction speeds
cost anything that you could come up
with that is
something that would be important for a
currency the number one thing to
optimize for is security
and as we have seen with a lot of
technologies right facebook's uh libra
or now what's known as dm is a great
example
uh not having decentralization is
susceptible to
the nation state and so a lot of these
other
platforms and blockchains uh they say
security is
important but it's not the most
important thing right we believe there's
a trade-off between
you know a little less security and
transaction speed or
composability or whatever it is and so
take ethereum as kind of the
second largest community in blockchain
by market cap
it was created because somebody wanted
to a group of people wanted to do
something on bitcoin they felt like they
couldn't do it and so they said hey
we're going to go create something that
has these smart contracts that we can
then go do here
again this is technology right so the
tribalism of like you're right you're
wrong to me is a little childish just in
the sense of like the market is going to
decide what is most valuable
and then when you go inside of that
community like there's a lot of dumb
ideas people are trying to build around
bitcoin
there's also a lot of really really
great ideas people trying to build
around bitcoin
same thing in the ethereum world and so
what you end up getting i think is the
tribalism really comes out of the idea
that there's a ticker price
that is attached to all of this right if
you go back
in history of technology venture
capitalists didn't sit around
the table and yell and scream at each
other in this like religious zealot way
right because you bet on one type of
cloud computing platform and i bet on
another one
right just the market's going to
desirable it's going to work on and try
to make ours successful
uh here i think that the sensitivity and
mainly it comes out of the bitcoin
community
is that a lot of this is being funded
not only by
venture capitalists and kind of
professional money managers and asset
allocators there's also this element of
including the
retail investor and the public and so it
whether it's through
icos or some other forms of capital
raising
there's arguments for it saying hey look
uh this now gives
kind of the little guy some sort of
access and ability to do it
but there's also arguments against it
some people say hey it's easier to dupe
them and it's easier to run scams and
kind of all this stuff and so
ultimately i think that uh crypto is
this like
arena of ideas it is literally the war
of attrition
and uh what will end up happening is 10
years from now you and i will talk
and we're going to say well the market
said x was valuable and y wasn't
and so all of the tribalism from between
you know here and there
uh it's fun it's you know engaging
whatever but also it doesn't really
matter yeah because the public is
involved
there's a lot of personalities and so a
lot of times we focus on the ex
extreme personalities that do a lot of
maybe uh
pardon the french [ __ ] talking and and
so we kind of focus on that
but that's not necessarily
representative of the communities
involved
you